RONALD SMITH: OK, so we're going
to do the stratospheric
ozone problem today.
And these are the new
terminology you
should be aware of.
So we'll talk about the ozone
layer and then the ozone hole.
The Dobson unit I'll discuss,
I'll define as a measure of
column integrated ozone
concentration.
We'll be talking about CFCs
which had been used as the
primary liquid in
refrigerators.
And you need to have a fluid
that flows back and forth
between the cold sink and the
warm sink in a refrigerator.
And CFCs was the common
chemical to do that.
But now they've been replaced
largely by HCFCs, the
hydrochlorofluorocarbons.
Say that 10 times fast. And so
I'll define those as well.
We'll talk at some point today
about polar stratospheric
clouds, catalytic reactions,
which are reactions in which
one particular chemical compound
allows the reaction
to go forward but in the end
itself isn't changed.
So it can be reused over and
over again to make the same
chemical cycle go forward.
Photochemical reactions, which
are chemical reactions that
involve light.
You have to have photons of
light in order for that
reaction to go forward.
And we'll talk about the
Montreal Protocol.
So all this will come
in turn today.
First of all, I showed this
diagram last time as we
discussed this part of the ozone
issue, but now we're
going to talk about
the ozone layer.
And as it says here, contains
90% of the atmospheric ozone.
So if you do a column
integration from the top of
the atmosphere to the bottom,
most of the contribution comes
from the ozone layer.
What's plotted here is the
partial pressure of ozone in
milliPascals.
Remember that the total
pressure, the air pressure,
decreases strongly and
exponentially all the way on
up through the troposphere
and the stratosphere.
So this has a very different
vertical structure than the
total pressure.
It has a beneficial role, it
acts as a shield against
ultraviolet radiation that would
otherwise cause skin
cancer, skin damage.
And the current trends are a
long-term global downtrend in
stratospheric ozone.
And then most famously, this
ozone hole which occurs in the
springtime of the Antarctic part
of the earth each year.
And then some more recent
discussion about possibly this
starting up in the Northern
Hemisphere as well, but this
is not as well documented.
So just a couple of
calculations then.
So I want to compute the mixing
ratio in ppmv for ozone
to air using this point
on this slide.
So I'm going to say that at
about 24 kilometers altitude
you've got a partial pressure
of ozone that's about 30
milliPascals.
And I want to convert that to a
mixing ratio because that's
what we've been used to using,
what we used last time.
So first of all, because it's
going to be a mixing ratio you
need to know how much air is up
there as well, not just how
much ozone, but how much air.
So I'm going to use this simple
formula that we've used
quite often in the course.
It's the approximate exponential
form for pressure
as a function of altitude
where you use a scale
height, H sub s.
You know the pressure at the
surface of the earth, you know
the altitude you're inquiring
about, and this will give you
the pressure at that altitude
So sea level pressure we'll take
to be 1,013 millibars,
which is the standard
average value,
convert that to Pascals.
The scale height as you recall
is RT over g, which is about
8,400 meters for the earth--the
earth's atmosphere.
So I'll put 24 kilometers up
here, that scale height there,
and I'll put the sea level
pressure there, and that's
this formula here.
So I put everything where I said
I would and I get a value
of about 6,000 Pascals for
the air pressure up here.
And then I can simply put that
into a ratio of the two
pressures to get the mixing
ratio in the common units.
So I put in that the value of
0.03/6,000, I get 20 ppmv for
the ozone mixing ratio in the
peak of the ozone layer.
OK?
Pretty straightforward
calculation.
Had to find out how much air
was there and then from the
proper ratio get it in
the proper units.
Now compare this to what we were
talking about last time.
The EPA one hour standard for
ozone in the boundary layer,
where we live, was 0.12
in those same units.
So the ozone concentration in
the ozone layer is about 200
times the EPA one hour limit,
just to give you a relative
sense for that.
So if we were up there, that
would be really tough for us
to breathe that in.
Now remember however, there's
not enough air to keep us
alive anyway at those
altitudes.
But the ozone concentration
is quite large as well.
So that's an inhospitable
environment up
there at that altitude.
Any questions on that?
But it is possible, or it was
until recently, possible for
us to fly at those altitudes.
So the Concorde, this beautiful,
supersonic,
commercial airliner which
stopped flying a couple years
ago, it flew at an altitude
typically of 17 kilometers,
which isn't quite at the peak
of the ozone concentration,
but it's definitely up in the
ozone layer, there's no doubt
about that.
And of course, you have to
refresh the cabin air.
You can't just lock the cabin
doors and expect everybody to
live off that cabin air until
you get to your destination.
So the aircraft can continually
draw in air from
outside to flush the cabin and
give you fresh cabin air.
The question is how do you
do that in this case?
Remember though that there's
two problems. First of all,
there's very little air
outside anyway.
So you're going to have to
compress it with some kind of
a pump before you can put it
into the cabin so people can
breathe it.
And that's going to be
a big compression.
Let's just think about
this for a minute.
So if you're flying at 17
kilometers and you want to get
that air compressed to cabin
pressure, well first of all
what cabin pressure do
you normally have?
Airliners don't usually keep
you at sea level pressure.
If you're taking off from New
York City, as you take off the
pressure will drop--
in the cabin will drop as you
climb, but they'll usually
only let it drop to maybe an
equivalent altitude of 6,000
feet, something like that.
Then they couldn't let it go
any lower or you'd start to
have trouble breathing,
but they don't
keep you at sea level.
So I'm going to assume that the,
for this calculation that
the cabin altitude, what's
called the cabin altitude, is
going to be kept at
2 kilometers.
That's about 6,000 feet
above the surface.
In fact, you're flying at 17
kilometers, so you've got to
take air and compress it just
as you would if you took a
parcel of air from 17 kilometers
and brought it down
to two kilometers, it would
compress, adiabatic
compression, we've
talked about this
over and over again.
And it would heat as
you compress it.
So when you put it into that
pump and compress it, it's
going to warm up,
and how much?
Well this is a calculation
you can do in your head.
You know the adiabatic lapse
rate is about 10 degrees per
kilometer, actually it's 9.8,
but I've rounded it off.
That's a difference in 15
kilometers, so essentially
you're going to get 150 degrees
Celsius warming when
you compress that air
about ready to
put it into the cabin.
Now you're going to--it started
off pretty cold, but
still that's going to
be really hot air.
Two things I've got
to say about that.
First of all, the convenient
thing is that that temperature
will destroy the ozone.
So just by compressing the air,
getting it ready to put
into the cabin, you're going
to kill off that ozone
automatically.
So that's pretty convenient.
But then remember, you're going
to have to cool it a bit
before you put it
into the cabin.
So you're going to put it
through another heat
exchanger, cool it back down,
and then you get the air to
stick into the cabin.
If you don't get it all out, you
can pass the air through
an activated charcoal filter
and that will remove any
remaining ozone that's
in the air before you
put it into the cabin.
So it is possible to fly at
those altitudes right in the
middle of the ozone layer.
But that's how you
have to do it.
Any questions on that?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Why would you
want to fly at
that high of an altitude?
PROFESSOR: It turns out it has
mostly to do with
the efficiency of the engines.
In fact, that's true with
subsonic aircraft as well.
The reason they fly quite high,
35,000 feet, 37,000 feet
is because the engines are most
efficient at that altitude.
And for this aircraft, the more
efficient--the altitude
was even higher at
17 kilometers.
So anything on that?
OK, maybe that's a little
tangential point, but--
This thing called the Dobson
unit is a column density.
We could write it, in fact, I
wish that they had chosen the
unit of kilograms per
square meter.
You'd simply integrate top to
bottom in the atmosphere and
say how many kilograms of ozone
are there in each square
meter of footprint for
that column that
you've integrated over.
But for historic reasons they
didn't do it that way.
This is typically measured by
looking at light coming from
the sun and see how much
ultraviolet light reaches the
surface of the earth.
And that will tell you
how much ozone
there is in the column.
What they're using for the
Dobson unit is this
definition, it's 1
milli-atmosphere-centimeters.
That's the scientific definition
of a Dobson unit.
And here's how you
think about that.
You take all the ozone in the
column, you compress it to
standard temperature and
pressure, that is 1 atmosphere
of pressure and 0
degrees Celsius.
And then you measure how thick
that layer would be composed
just of ozone and you measure
that in thousandth of a
centimeter.
And that is your Dobson
unit value.
And I'll be showing you
this kind of data.
Typical values for the earth's
atmosphere run from 100 to 500
Dobson units depending
on where you
are around the world.
But that is normally--
the Dobson is what we use to
describe to each other how
much ozone there is
in the atmosphere.
So for example, you'll see a
diagram like this from NASA.
It's a map of the world and
some areas are blocked out
because they don't have data
from here for this particular
time of year.
But the scale is in
Dobson units.
So in the tropical regions
you're getting values of about
250, 260 Dobson units.
In the green you're getting
values maybe 325, maybe in
some areas even 350 or 360.
So that's the way we represent
column integrated ozone in
this subject.
We can also get vertical profile
information either by
direct in situ measurements or
by looking at light passing
across the earth's atmosphere
horizontally.
This gives you some idea where
the ozone layer is as a
function of latitude.
So here's latitude,
North Pole, South
Pole, Equator, altitude.
But notice the offset 0, this
isn't the ground, this is
starting at 16 kilometers,
right?
So the ozone layer at higher
latitudes, it peaks at an
altitude of about 20 kilometers,
18, 19, 20
kilometers.
But near the Equator, it's up
around 25, 26 kilometers.
I think we expected this
because remember the
tropopause has the same
kind of a structure.
It's higher in the equatorial
regions and lower
in the polar regions.
So the ozone layer is about
the same place in the
stratosphere, but the
stratosphere starts at a
different level.
So it's lifted in a sense
relative to the surface of the
earth in the equatorial
latitudes.
The reason why--part of the
reason why there is that
difference is because of a broad
circulation that takes
place in the stratosphere calls
call the Brewer-Dobson
circulation, which I won't talk
about, but this artist
has reminded us that there is
this broad slow circulation in
the stratosphere.
So why do we have ozone
in the stratosphere?
This is a basic chemistry
of that.
We know we have a lot of O2 in
our atmosphere, it's the
second most common molecule.
And occasionally, a high
energy photon will
come from the sun.
A high energy ultraviolet photon
will dissociate that
diatomic oxygen into two oxygen
atoms. It doesn't
happen very often because
it needs a high energy
photon to do that.
But then you've got some free
oxygen atoms floating around.
And when you have that, that'll
quickly combine with
an O2 molecule to form ozone.
That's a fast reaction.
But equally fast is that other
ultraviolet photons, they
don't have to be as energetic
as this one, these can be in
the near, or in the UVA, for
example, the near ultraviolet,
will dissociate that
back to this again.
And that's fast.
So what you've got is a rapid
recycling going on between
that and that that's just going
out all the time in the
stratosphere, but maintaining
a balance here.
Now occasionally an ozone will
interact with one of these
atoms and go back to go to O2,
which is the common form.
And then you've lost it.
So you've lost the ozone
permanently or at least quasi
permanently.
So the ozone concentration is
controlled by--ignoring this
rapid cycling which doesn't have
any long-term effect, is
controlled by the balance of
these two slow processes.
How often are you producing
oxygen atoms and how often are
you removing ozone and oxygen
atoms back to O2?
And that would be occurring
naturally because we have
oxygen in the atmosphere and
we have ultraviolet light
coming from the sun.
So that's the background to
why there is ozone in the
stratosphere.
The reason why it doesn't happen
further down is because
most of these ultraviolet
photons are absorbed up there
and don't get--don't penetrate
deeper into the atmosphere.
So it's a layer up there because
that's where these
ultraviolet photons are being
absorbed and doing this work
causing these photochemical
reactions to take place.
Questions on that?
STUDENT: I'm curious if there
is some sort of feedback
mechanism or if the two slow
reactions are interconnected
in some way.
Because I guess if you have more
free oxygen atoms that
would allow the second process
to occur more frequently?
PROFESSOR: Well you'd have to
write down the
rate equations for these to
answer that question, which
I'm not prepared to do.
But a chemical reaction, the
rate at which it goes forward
depends on how much of this do
you have, and how much of this
do you have, and how often are
they colliding to allow the
reaction to go forward?
So I think your instinct is
right that these are going to
depend on the concentrations
that you have.
So just like our tank
experiment, the loss rate was
proportional to how much you
have. And that's what, in a
system like this where the
generation term is independent
of how much of this you have,
but the loss rate is
proportional, you're going to
come to an equilibrium, just
like we did in the water tank.
And that's what I'm implying
here, that you've got that
kind of balance between a source
which is just there and
then a sink which is dependent
on how much you have. And that
will give a natural equilibrium
eventually.
And this is a cartoon
showing that.
So the sun is playing a role.
Occasionally it will dissociate
O2 to form a simple
O, an O molecule.
And then you get this rapid
recycling between
oxygen atoms and ozone.
And then occasionally, you'll go
back just to the O2 again.
And the control of how much you
have is primarily these
processes, not this.
This is just a rapid recycling
of the two
types of odd oxygen.
Now to remind you about the
spectrum of radiation coming
from the sun, I show you this,
you've seen it before.
The visible spectrum is here,
the infrared, we're really
interested in the ultraviolet
over here in today's
conversation, which starts at
400 nanometers wavelength and
goes shorter than that.
And these standard definitions
are helpful.
UVA are the wavelengths closest
to the visible,
closest to the blue, defined
as going from 400 to 315
nanometers.
UVB, 315 to 280, and then UVC,
280 all the way down to 100
nanometers.
Now you may remember from
physics of that the shorter
wavelength photons are
more energetic,
they'll do more damage.
So UVA would cause tanning of
your skin, but probably
wouldn't give you skin
cancer, UVB might.
But UVC is very damaging.
In fact, it's used in
doctor's offices to
clean surgical tools.
You put it into this autoclave
which will put UVC on your
instruments and it'll kill
anything that's there very,
very quickly.
It's very damaging radiation.
And so here's the fate
of UVA, UVB, and UVC.
Some UVA comes through.
Half or more of the UVB is
absorbed in the ozone layer,
plotted on top of this.
This is altitude and Dobson
units per kilometer to get
where the ozone layer is.
So about 1/2 or 2/3 of the UVB
is absorbed by the ozone.
And almost all, thankfully, of
the UVC coming from the sun is
absorbed by the ozone layer.
So it's a very good protective
shield for us.
Now what could be changing this
natural ozone layer situation?
Well this is the current
theory for it.
It involves a catalytic reaction
primarily using
chlorine atoms. Now bromine will
do this as well and there
is some bromine in the
atmosphere, but I'm going to
focus strictly on
the chlorine.
And notice how this
reaction works.
So you have a chlorine
atom reacting
with an ozone molecule.
It goes to ClO, it oxidizes
the chlorine and
gives you back O2.
And then quite soon after that,
you'll take this ClO and
react it with another
ozone molecule.
That'll give you back the Cl
that you started with and you
have two O2s, two regular
diatomic oxygens.
So look, the ozone is gone.
In fact, two ozones are gone.
And you've got your Cl back
ready to do it again.
So this is a catalytic reaction
where the catalyst
here is the chlorine atom.
It can be used over and over
again to destroy ozone
molecules in this way.
Two ozone molecules are lost
and the catalyst is free,
ready to go back,
and do it again.
That's the idea of what's today,
now that we have a
measurable chlorine
concentration in the
atmosphere, this is why we
think the ozone layer is
decreasing.
Questions on that?
So up here in the inset
is the emission.
This is an example,
CFC 11, one of the
chlorofluorocarbons.
And here's the emission rate
for it in megatons per year
starting in 1960 going
up to the year 2000.
So you see there was a rapid
rise in it as it was being
used in refrigeration.
And when you put it into a
refrigerator, it may be
contained for a few years, but
eventually it leaks out or
someone tosses away the
refrigerator and it gets a
leak and it goes to
the atmosphere.
So almost everything you produce
eventually makes its
way into the atmosphere.
The Montreal Protocol that
I'll talk about was here,
where you begin to see
it finally decreased.
But because it's a long lived
molecule, here's the CFC
abundance in the atmosphere,
it increased through this
period of time, we've stopped
putting it in,
but it's still there.
It has a lifetime--from this
data, it looks like the
lifetime is about 50 years.
And so it's going to take
probably another 50 or 100
before we see much
of a decline.
Thank goodness we've stopped
putting it in, but it's not
going to decrease to 0
just because we've
stopped putting it in.
It's going to be stored in the
atmosphere for a while.
It has a long lifetime.
The circles are data from the
Northern Hemisphere and the
triangles are data from the
Southern Hemisphere.
But they're pretty
much the same.
So the two hemispheres,
this stuff gets
mixed back and forth.
Probably most of it was put
into the atmosphere in the
Northern Hemisphere, but now
it's mixed to be pretty much
equal in the two hemispheres.
Questions on that?
Here is the global averaged
total ozone change in percent
starting back in 1965.
Around 1980 is when we began to
see the rapid decrease, but
it's not a huge.
Notice that it's leveled out
today and it's only about 4%
below where it started.
So this global decrease in
ozone is, I suppose it's
something we should be concerned
about, but it's not
a huge factor.
And it doesn't look like it's
going to get any worse now
that we've stopped putting
CFCs into the atmosphere.
So it's a concern, but
not I would say a
terribly difficult one.
But then there's this ozone hole
that I'll spend the rest
of time talking about.
And here's what it looked like
a couple of days ago.
You can go to this website,
which I'm just about to do.
I should have set
this up before.
But here's a definition of it.
So it's a brief, seasonal and
local reduction in ozone.
Location is Antarctica, the time
of year that it happens
each year is September,
October.
It first appeared in about 1978,
apparently it wasn't
happening before then.
It was discovered in 1984 and
then going back and looking at
old data, they found that it
actually had started some six
years earlier than that.
The discovery of the depletion
mechanism by Molina and
Crutzen was a rather
remarkable scientific discovery.
I'll give you hints of how that
went in just a minute.
And they won the Nobel Prize in
chemistry for that awarded
in 1995 from that discovery
of how the ozone depletion
mechanism works.
Ultimately, it's caused by these
CFC emissions which then
led to the Montreal Protocol,
which I'll talk briefly about,
a rather successful
international treaty to limit
the emissions of CFCs.
Here's a brief history of it.
So at the top is the ozone
hole area in millions of
square kilometers.
What you do is set a threshold
for ozone concentration.
If it's lower than that you
say you're in the hole, if
it's larger than that you're
out of the hole.
And then you keep track
of that area.
And the ozone hole was
nonexistent before '79.
But now it has reached about 25
million square kilometers,
you saw a picture of it.
And it's kind of leveled out,
it's not getting it better not
getting any worse.
And the minimum ozone in the
middle of that hole is shown
here in Dobson units, of course,
getting worse but now
leveling out to a value of about
100 Dobson units in the
middle of the hole each
year when it forms.
So give me just a moment here
to bring up this website.
I forgot to do this before.
Let's see here.
I'll just Google and find it.
Yeah, that's probably it.
That's not the one I want.
That's a good one, but it's not
the one I'm looking for.
I'll try to find
this other one.
Yeah, let's do an animation
for this season.
I'll try this one.
Yeah, so this is this
year's hole.
It hasn't formed yet,
we're back in July.
This is Antarctica sitting
there waiting.
Now wait until we get
into September.
It's already beginning to form
in the late summer, but now
we're getting the ozone
hole forming.
October, peaks in October, and
then it'll start to fill in up
to the present date.
It's starting to weaken now
that we're into November.
So that's the deal.
It happens every year
in that region.
You get this large area that
forms with about half the
ozone it would otherwise have.
Ozone depletion is about 50
percent in that region compared
to remember only 4
percent percent globally.
So this is a localized
anomaly.
You can go to that website
yourself and do some other
animations.
So in this year then this tracks
it, the ozone hole area
climbed up to the 12th of
September, now it's decreased.
The minimum ozone dropped to a
minimum now it's increasing
now that we're into November.
And I'm going to be talking
about the stratospheric
temperature.
Stratospheric temperature in
that part of the world now at
that altitude is beginning to
climb because we're getting
out of their winter and towards
of their Southern
Hemisphere summer.
And I'll come back to talk about
the role of temperature
in just a moment.
So I think the most curious
thing about the ozone hole is
why only in September
and October?
Why just over the South Pole?
And I guess what is the link
to human activity?
So there's a lot of natural
processes and factors
controlling this.
And then there's the added
impact of humans and somehow
they have all come together to
form this curious phenomena of
the ozone hole.
In the few minutes I have left
I want to just try to explain
some of that.
Now I hope you can see this,
I'll read it through for you.
This is the seasonal cycle
of temperature in the
stratosphere.
And this is for 90 North
to 65 North, so this is
the north polar cap.
This is 25 North to 25
South, so this is
the equatorial region.
And this is 65 South to 90
South, so this is the south
polar region.
Now the temperatures in the
Northern Hemisphere get down
to minus 70 on occasion.
These are at different
altitudes, I believe, having
trouble reading those.
They get down to minus 70.
In the equatorial regions, those
temperatures get down to
about minus 75.
But here in the South Pole, they
get down to minus 80 and
even minus 85.
So of all the places in the
world's stratosphere, the
Southern Hemisphere polar
stratosphere, that is over
Antarctica, has a winter time
temperature colder than any
other place on the planet.
That's one of the things that
makes it special in regards to
why the ozone hole
forms there.
Now why would that be?
It has to do with the
phenomena of polar
stratospheric clouds,
abbreviation PSCs.
Polar stratospheric clouds.
I haven't spoken about these
in the course up to this
present time, so this
is new material.
These are ice clouds that form
up in the stratosphere.
Normally we think clouds don't
form in the stratosphere, it's
pretty dry up there, but
these clouds do.
They are not entirely
made of water.
They're a mixture of water and
nitric acid in these clouds.
And they require an
extraordinarily cold
temperature in order to form,
temperatures colder than minus
70 degrees Celsius, some would
say even colder than that.
This is probably why the
Antarctic stratosphere is so
special because it's temperature
gets cold enough
in winter to allow these polar
stratospheric clouds to occur,
whereas other places around the
globe in the stratosphere
you don't get those clouds.
What do they do then?
How do they influence ozone?
Well these ice clouds, these
ice particles, freeze up
diatomic chlorine by
holding the nitric
acid in the ice itself.
Notice when it forms it's
storing HNO3, nitric acid.
And here's the reaction.
You start with HCl, and ClONO2,
reaction goes to Cl2
and the nitric acid, and then
this is locked up in the ice.
So what you've done, you had
your chlorine locked up in HCl
and in this compound, there's
chlorines in both.
Now you've put the nitric acid
in the ice and you've freed up
the chlorine diatomic
molecule.
There's only one step to go.
When the light returns,
remember, that minimum of
temperature occurred in
perpetual darkness.
At that season of the year,
it's dark over Antarctica,
there's no light.
So you can get the ice forming,
you can get the Cl
all ready to go, but it's
in the diatomic form.
Then the light comes back,
Southern Hemisphere spring,
the light comes back, you can
dissociate the Cl2 to form two
Cl molecules.
And then go back a few slides to
that catalytic reaction and
it starts to destroy ozone.
So you get that?
So the ice frees up the
chlorine, it then dissociates
when light returns, and the
catalytic destruction of ozone
begins to take place, and the
ozone hole forms. That's why
it occurs where it does and when
it does because of that
necessary condition for cold.
And then the ozone hole forms
just after the light returns
to that region.
Any questions on that?
Yes?.
STUDENT: Where does the
hydrochloric acid
come from, the HCl?
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
That's the way the chlorine is
stored most of the time in the
stratosphere, is in these
two molecules.
After the CFCs break down, the
chlorine is transferred into
these two forms and
just hangs around.
Then the PSCs form and that
sucks off the nitric acid and
the Cl is released.
So this is the storage form of
the chlorine during most of
the year in the stratosphere.
STUDENT: Is there normally
chlorine in the atmosphere
besides the HCI?
PROFESSOR: Not naturally.
Remember this was CFCs
and not chlorine.
And that's a critical
difference.
But let me just go
back to that.
There were no CFCs in the
atmosphere before that.
There probably was a little bit
of chlorine, but only a
very small amount.
But now we're putting it in
through this CFC source.
Sorry, that's not a complete
answer, but that's
the best I can do.
So I think this-yeah, this
is the last one.
So the Montreal Protocol, the
full name of it is Montreal
Protocol on Substances that
Deplete the Ozone layer.
It's an international treaty.
And of course it was first
signed in Montreal,
it's got the name.
Since then it has been modified
several times.
Certain forms of substances have
been added to the banned
list, others have
been allowed.
So it's been modified
a few times.
Generally what it did is by the
time we came to 1994, it
had banned pretty much all
emissions of CFCs into the
atmosphere.
It largely replaced them with
the HCFC, which can also be
used as a refrigerant, but has
a much shorter lifetime and
will not cause the chlorine to
build up in the atmosphere.
It may have some other
problems, it may be a
greenhouse gas.
But it doesn't have the problem
of putting permanently
chlorine into the atmosphere
the way that the CFCs do.
Now one of the reasons why
this treaty was signed,
because as you'd expect the
refrigerant industry
vigorously opposed this, was
at about the time it was
signed, Dupont which was this
large chemical company and the
world's largest producer
of CFCs, discovered a
replacement for it.
And they realized that they
would not lose their business
because they had a replacement
ready to go and they might
even be able to make more money
by doing this changeover
to a different type
of refrigerant.
So in the end, they dropped
their opposition and many
countries of the world got
together and signed this
international treaty.
And it's viewed in environmental
circles as being
one of the best examples of a
successful situation where the
scientists discovered the
problem, suggested how to
solve it, and then you have
the countries of the world
actually getting together
to pass a treaty
and acting on it.
As you saw, the CFC emissions
have dropped nearly to 0 now.
So it's looked at as, well in
some cases, in wonderment
because how could we do
something like this today,
it's not clear.
But at least we have this
example of how environmental
science can prevent
these problems.
Any questions on this?
Great we're done a little
bit early again today.
So enjoy your Thanksgiving break
and I'll see you a week
from Monday.